but what we saw in yesterday's vote was
a clear majority in support of the prime
minister what we've been doing today is
getting on with the business of
government we've had a cabinet meeting
we're working on making housing more
affordable making childcare more
affordable lowering taxes and that's
what the public wants us to be doing on
the prime minister's authority though if
we go back to that first question has it
been undermined
as i've said the prime minister remains
committed to our agenda he's already
delivered on brexit he's delivered on
covid on helping the economy recover
he's delivered on supporting ukraine in
the face of appalling russian aggression
and that's what the cabinet wanted him
to carry on doing and that's what the
country wants him to carry on doing
so what's your message to those 148 of
your colleagues who declared they had no
confidence in the party leader
my message is we had a vote yesterday
there was a clear result in that vote
now is the time to get behind the prime
minister to deliver on what people in
britain want to see which is dealing
with issues around the affordability of
housing the affordability of child care
getting taxes down getting our economy
going that's what people want to see and
what does this mean with regard to your
ambitions potentially for the leadership
of the party
my 100 focus is on my role as foreign
secretary there's a lot to do we need to
carry on supporting ukraine
we need to make sure that russia is
driven out of ukraine and that we get
successful peace for ukraine we need to
help them rebuild i'm also working on
the northern iron protocol making sure
we restore the balance of the belfast
good friday agreement bringing forward
legislation and i can assure you that is
taking up all of my time should
colleagues feel able to continue to
criticize the prime minister
well we had a vote yesterday the prime
minister won a clear majority it's time
to draw a line move forward and focus on
what people want us to be talking about
housing child care delivering on lower
taxes now you mentioned the northern
ireland protocol
are you willing to risk a trade war with
the european union to sort it all out
what we want to do is create clear green
lanes for goods flowing into northern
ireland and a red lane for goods flowing
into the eu that will protect the eu
single market
at the same time as enabling goods to
flow freely around the uk that's a
win-win for both the people of northern
ireland and protecting the eu single
market and you also mentioned bringing
taxes down lord frost today has said
that the nor the national insurance
increase should be reversed that the
corporation tax rise should not go ahead
do you agree well today at cabinet the
prime minister confirmed that he wants
to see taxes come down that is very very
important we need to make sure people
have more money in their pockets we need
to get the economy going and the way to
do that is lowering taxes thank you